felipe está descargando aplicaciones y
canciones en su tableta descargó 7
aplicaciones y 6 canciones cada canción
tarda en descargarse un promedio de 0.8
minutos más que cada aplicación si tarda
alrededor de 21.7 minutos para que se
complete la descarga cuál de los
siguientes sistemas puede usarse para
aproximarse aa el número promedio de
minutos que tarda en bajar una
aplicación y ese el número promedio de
minutos que tarda en descargarse una
canción muy bien entonces bueno vamos a
iniciar escribiendo expresiones que
representen el tiempo que tarda felipe
en descargar las canciones y las
aplicaciones ahora usando la información
que tenemos en el texto dado que felipe
descargó siete aplicaciones y el tiempo
promedio que tarda una aplicación en
descargarse es a minutos
ah entonces bueno tenemos siete
aplicaciones y cada aplicación tarda en
descargarse a minutos así que tomó siete
por a minutos en descargarse las
aplicaciones jaja entonces tomó siete
minutos el total de la descarga de las
aplicaciones de manera similar
felipe descargó seis canciones y el
promedio de tiempo que tarda cada
canción en descargarse son s minutos
entonces como fueron seis canciones y
cada canción tarda s minutos en
descargarse tomó 6 x s minutos en
descargarse el total de las canciones
también sabemos otra cosa
sabemos que el total de tiempo que tardó
en descargarse todo es decir las
aplicaciones y las canciones fueron 21
puntos 7 minutos
así que tenemos la siguiente ecuación
+ 6 s es igual a 21.7 21.7 es el total
de tiempo que tardó en descargarse todo
que más sabemos sabemos que cada canción
tarda en promedio 0.8 minutos más en
descargarse que cada aplicación y esta
información la podemos poner en la
siguiente ecuación s igual a más 0.8
donde esa es la cantidad de tiempo que
tarda en descargarse una canción en la
cantidad de tiempo que tarda en
descargarse una aplicación y bueno lo
que estamos aquí diciendo es que la
cantidad de tiempo que tarda en
descargarse una canción es igual a la
descargarse una aplicación más 0.8
minutos porque cada canción tarda en
promedio 0.8 minutos más en descargarse
cada aplicación
y ahora vamos a considerar las dos
ecuaciones juntas ya tenemos estas dos
ecuaciones 7 a 6
es igual a 21.7 y ese es igual a 0.8
entonces vamos a hacer un reacomodo de
la ecuación de abajo lo que vamos a
hacer es pasar al 0.8 restando entonces
tenemos a es igual a ese menos 0.8
simplemente pongo a la de lado izquierdo
y ese menos 0.8 del lado derecho por lo
tanto el sistema que puede utilizarse
para aproximarse al valor de a el
promedio de minutos que tarda en
descargarse una aplicación y ese el
descargarse una canción es este sistema
7 a más 6 s es igual a 21.7 ya iguala s
menos 0.8 así que
aquí está la respuesta y las otras bueno
no es igual a lo que obtuvimos entonces
éstas están mal así que la respuesta
correcta es esta